and we're joined now on the programme by
the deputy leader of the labour party
angela raynor ms reiner very good
morning to you
morning
so tell us what do you make of the
explanation such as it is
about the resignation of allegra
stratton about the parties that seem to
be taking across whitehall there is an
investigation now underway is that
enough
well it doesn't wash with me or the
general public i don't think i wrote to
the cabinet secretary last week asking
for an investigation into the one party
that we knew about at the time and the
prime minister at the time was saying
nothing to see here nothing happened i
find it incredulous that the prime
minister is saying that he didn't know
anything about a party at number 10 he's
now an alleged gathering party event
within his own flat they've had him also
at the conservative headquarters i mean
it's just fragrantly disregard and
laughing at the public and taking them
for fools around the rules but what i
will say and what i think is really
important and this is why labour have
been supporting the efforts and want us
to go further in terms of providing sick
pay and ventilation in our schools we we
have to follow these guidance because
it's not what boris johnson says it's
about keeping us all safe because the
chief medical officer and the science
says that we need to take this action to
protect ourselves and to protect the nhs
who have been you know diligently
looking after us throughout this
pandemic and we know winter is a
difficult time for our nhs so we do have
to act responsibly and by the way the
vast majority of the public understand
this and have been doing it and that's
why they're really angry at the prime
minister
allowing
this to happen under his watch within
the heart of downing street is an
absolute disgrace and he's got trap
records you know this is a guy in every
elected position that he's ever held
he's broke the rules so it's his time's
up you can't do it as prime minister
especially not when lives are at risk
sure but but from what you've just said
and the support given by the shadow
health secretary to the move to plan b
yesterday you don't feel unlike some
conservative mps in fact that the rather
abrupt move to plan b was in any way
linked to that release of the video
showing
most likely that a party did take place
in number 10 and the rules were broken
well you know what's really important is
that you know we had a meeting and
kirsten spoke to the chief medical
officer and you know had a briefing from
those in the position of knowledge who
said that we need to take these measures
so the labour party are clear that we're
following the medical and the science
and expert advice on this and we
hope that people will do that boris
johnson has completely undermined those
efforts and we you know it's incredibly
disappointing i am calling on the
government today to provide sick pay for
people this is a massive big problem
when it comes to people being able to do
the right thing and self-isolate they
need sick pace so that that can happen
and that will help control the virus and
we need to make sure that we have proper
ventilation in schools it's cold this
time of year many schools have still not
got adequate ventilation we know this
would help and we know the infection
spreads in school so we're calling on
the government to really step up their
efforts to make sure that people have
got access to the booster jobs access to
vaccines but also they fix six pet sick
pay and that they start out the
situation with ventilation in our
schools
we also know that you know despite the
prime minister's entreaty to us all to
continue with our christmas parties the
measures announced yesterday uh well and
indeed just the current vibe around
government not exactly lending itself to
confidence within the hospitality sector
it feels as if they will start losing
money now if if not in the in the
immediate future
is the labour party's position that
there should once again be some form of
financial assistance for businesses who
are affected by the increased
restrictions
well what was important is that if you
look at what the welsh look at labour
government did they brought in the
vaccine passports and testing negative
testing some time ago which gave
business the opportunity to respond to
this the government have to support
business to ensure that they can take
adequate measures so that that people
can be safe and can go out to events in
a safe manner we're also asking people
to if you are going to a christmas party
or you are going to an event where
there'll be more people and it's
particularly indoors is that you do take
a test beforehand so that you know
you're not carrying the virus we can all
act responsibly so that we can continue
to
live as normal life as possible and we
think the government should do that but
you know doing it last minute is a
problem for businesses they they find it
very difficult especially this being
their busiest time of year to respond to
last minute changes and we feel like the
government should have been planning for
this some time ago rather than bringing
it last minute for businesses and them
trying to adapt so the government really
do need to support business to to adapt
to the changes that we need to make
just a couple of questions if we can
away from covert for a second there was
there was an article um recently in the
manchester evening news saying that that
your son has asked you to step down from
from frontline politics because of the
the number of threats you've received
your mother believes that there are
people trying to trying to kill you what
what is the the extent of the of the
threats that are being made against you
at the moment if you don't mind me
asking
well and and
and unfortunately this isn't just a
singular issue for me it's cross-party
actually and it's a lot of and it's
predominantly female members of
parliament from all of the different
political parties seem to get a
significant amount of threats some of
them are death threats i've had death
threats against me threats against my
children told me that it wasn't hard to
find where i live and that i should do
them a favor and just kill myself rather
than them having to hunt me down like my
friend which was obviously the uh joe
cox who was who was a friend of mine who
was murdered in battle and spent so it's
pretty nasty stuff but you know the
police have been great manchester police
in particular have been incredibly
supportive and have been supporting me
and my family through it but my 12 and
13 year old have had to learn how to use
panic buttons and have escape routes
from our house and their lives have
changed because of it but the most
important thing to me is that these
people will not stop me doing my job and
representing
the constituents that i have the honor
to represent and that is what most mps
feel at the moment and it is a minority
who feel that you know they can try and
silence us as mps but that won't happen
because that is our democracy and we
have had a huge amount of support from
the police forces to make sure that we
can continue with our role but it is
upsetting and distressing for our family
and our staff who have to read through
countless levels of abuse that's level
that us and also unfortunately death
threats which like i say is not unique
to me
it has happened in a significant amount
of the time to many mps from all
different political parties
just just just before we let you go i
want to ask about the state of relations
between you and you and kirsten you were
sitting side by side at prime minister's
questions yesterday are you back to
being best buddies i'm just wondering
whether the suspension of your head of
communications jack mckenna might have
acted to stymie that perhaps
well me and kyr have had an incredibly
constructive relationship ever since we
became leader and deputy leader of the
labour party and we continue to do that
because we're both absolutely
clear that we need a labour government
and we work constructively together we
are different people of course we are
but you know kerry is the leader of the
labour party and i'm his deputy and we
work together you know very well
i won't comment on issues to do with
staff because i don't think that's
that's fair to do that there is
processes that go through and you know
those processes will continue and i
don't think it's it's right that that's
you know played out in the media as i
said before my staff have been through a
hell of a lot um coping with you know
helping constituents and supporting me
and doing my role so i i won't comment
on individual staff members but what i
will say is me and kyra are very clear
and have never departed from that and
continue to be joined together in making
sure that we show that we are a labor
government in waiting and that we will
change working people's lives and change
people's lives for the better once we're
in government
angela rainer good to have you on the
program this morning thanks for being
with us
thank you